Speaker 1: I want to start today talking a little
bit about so-called freedom, and the reason I say
so-called is because much of the discussion of
freedom, much of the use of the word freedom
is actually coming from extreme authoritarians
who only believe in the type of freedom that
benefits them. They only believe in the type of
freedom that allows them to impose whatever they
want on to everybody else restricting everybody
else's freedom. It's an extremely authoritarian
and historically popular with fascists perspective
on what freedom means, the freedom to tell others
what to do, for example, or the freedom to stay
in power. Even when you lost an election. It's
freedom to be extremely authoritarian, no matter
what anybody else wants, says or believes. And
in the past, we've talked about the people that
claim their rights. We saw this early with COVID
a lot. Actually, they focus on these are my
rights. They claim their rights, but they're
obsessed with their rights in a complete and total
vacuum from the responsibilities that come with
those rights and that allow everybody to maintain
those rights. And this is sort of a similar thing,
much the same way. Freedom during the pandemic
that's been preached by a lot of these people
means my version of freedom only, which is a
very authoritarian concept and perspective. And
you know, some examples by freedom the state of
Florida under Republican Governor Ron DeSantis is
a really good example. There's a very good article
in the Guardian that explains that the theme and
the concept of freedom pushed by DeSantis and the
Florida Legislature is actually authoritarianism
cloaked as freedom. Look at the so-called
Stop WOAK Act, and that imposes from above
from people who know nothing about education, what
is allowed to be taught in individual classrooms.
They talk about it as freedom, but it's actually
extremely authoritarian. Republicans are talking
about in Florida an extreme abortion ban without
even an exception for rape or incest. That's an
outrageously authoritarian way of telling women
what they have to do, outlawing mask requirements
in all sorts of places. That's not freedom and
liberty. It's authoritarian. You're imposing one
option on all sorts of organizations, despite
claiming to be about freedom. They claim to be
against regulating business. And yet they say we
are banning masking or vaccination requirements.
And even in the context of the Big Lie around
the 2020 election, they talk about the freedom
to have only legal votes counted. That's
what they say and all of these catchphrases.
But ultimately, all of it is in service to
the wildly dictatorial, authoritarian idea
that when you lose an election, you can find
some way to stay in power and there's few
things more dictatorial than that. There's some
really interesting research into the concept of
competitive authoritarianism. You can google that
phrase and you'll find a ton of academic papers
about it. And what competitive authoritarianism
refers to is you have, in theory, the front of
democratic institutions and electoral competition.
Whoever convinces voters that they are the better
candidate, the better choice wins and gets to
govern. But it's actually unfair competition
where incumbents try to use all sorts of
mechanisms, including courts. Remember Trump with
a 63 of five court filings, the media going out
at 2am and putting into the media the narrative
that I actually won manipulation of the voting
systems, telling and telling Georgia to do this
in Arizona to do that. They're using the courts,
media and the voting systems to stay in power
even when they lose, when there is a front of fair
democratic institutions. And that's a lot of what
2020 looked like. There's a very good Vox article
which says You what these people want to do
is strike a balance where they want to rig and
control elections just enough to stay in power.
But don't make it all look democratic so that
citizens believe they are choosing and they don't
rise up. And it often doesn't quite work. I mean,
it didn't quite work for them in 2020 and that
ultimately Joe Biden was still inaugurated the
president. But this concept of calling things
the opposite of what they are referring to a total
ban on mask mandates as freedom, when in reality,
it's the opposite of freedom. It's really. Lord
and fleshed out in detail in George Orwell's 1984,
it's almost cliche, it's almost apocryphal tons
of people love to misquote or misuse, or they
misunderstand aspects of 1984 and that they talk
about 1984 when it really doesn't apply. But this
opposite naming by authoritarians, it's straight
out of the book. In 1984, you have the slogan War
is peace. Freedom is slavery. That's fundamentally
at a core level what we're talking about here.
And in fact, one of the scariest things is that if
you look historically, fascism has a long history
of being called freedom. Fascism uses explicitly
populist, libertarian sounding rhetoric,
and they talk about, you know, a heroic mass
effort to get back to some previous period
where we had greatness. And we, you know, Trump
literally using the greatness thing. It often
demands loyalty to a single leader. It often leads
to a cult of personality and and unquestioned
obedience to whatever the leader says. He
says the election was stolen, it was stolen,
and we will all repeat it uncritically. Whether
we truly believe it or not historically reminds
us of many different things and sort of like the
calling card of those four years of Trump and
continues because the rallies have restarted,
which we'll talk about a little bit later.